hello a prominent Russian military
blogger and Kremlin supporter has been
killed in a bombing in Saint Petersburg
at least 32 people were injured a female
suspect has been arrested dorsa Jabari
reports from Moscow
this was the moment security cameras
captured the attack at the busy street
food bar number one Cafe in the heart of
Saint Petersburg on Sunday
the explosion killed 40-year-old
military blogger vladolin tatarsky who
was delivering a speech at the event
organized by The cyberfront Zed movement
an association of people with patriotic
views
they hold talks at this Cafe every week
over 100 people were in and around this
event at the time of the attack
the donbass native was given this statue
of himself as a gift moments before the
blast
according to the mayor of Saint
Petersburg all the city's Emergency
Services have been called in to deal
with the incident
bloodline tatarski launched his own
social media channel to report on the
activities of the Russian military in
its so-called special military operation
and has a following of over 500 000
subscribers tatarsky was invited to the
lavish ceremony last September at the
Kremlin where Russian president
proclaimed the annexation of four
regions of Ukraine
hatarski was a well-known figure among
Kremlin supporters seen here with Daria
duginao who was killed in a car bomb
attack last August in Moscow region her
father Alexander Dugan a far-right
political philosopher and Kremlin
supporter was believed to be the
intended target the Russian foreign
Ministry has issued a statement
condemning the attack and praising
tatarski's work as a journalist and his
service to his country
these types of attacks are rare in
Russia but the planning and plotting
behind them just prove that the battles
are not confined to the dumbass region
Moscow
we can now bring in dorsa she's joining
us from Moscow once again so what's the
latest in this case dorsa
well according to officials here a 26
year old woman by the name of Daria
trepova has been detained in Saint
Petersburg for what investigators
believed to be her involvement in this
attack
she was detained a short while ago in an
apartment about 40 minutes away from
this Cafe where the blast occurred this
is a woman that was a person of interest
the police were hunting for her since
late last night we believe and
investigators have said that they are
questioning her now they also questioned
members of her family on Sunday evening
according to local media in St
Petersburg this woman had purchased a
plane ticket to fly out of Russia on
Sunday to Uzbekistan now she is somebody
that is well known to officials in this
country she has been detained in the
past for her involvement in anti-war at
rallies that were ongoing after Russia
launched its so-called special military
operation in Ukraine last February we
are waiting to find out what the charges
will be brought against her but we know
that the special investigation committee
that is the state's main investigative
body in Russia has launched a murder
case in this incident so we'll know in
the coming hours the details of whether
or not she'll be arrested with she'll be
charged rather with first degree murder
in this case what we have heard from
officials and many local
reporters in St Petersburg is that this
is a clear premeditated attack there was
a bust a statue of tatarski that was
given to him as a gift by this woman at
this Cafe on Sunday evening right so any
indications as to who's responsible for
this
all right well many are speculating
initially that there was involvement by
the key of government without providing
any concrete evidence the Russian
foreign Ministry spokeswoman issued a
statement on Sunday evening saying that
at the Kiev regime is threatened by
journalists like tatarsky and their work
when it comes to this special military
operation as they call it many analysts
I've spoken to hear say this is this
could possibly be also a message to the
head of the Wagner group evgeny pagosian
who is the owner of this Cafe in Saint
Petersburg this was a location that is
handed over to this group that holds
these weekly talks in support of the
Russian military so some believe that
this could also be possibly an inside
job within the country to send a very
clear message to the Wagner group and
its head if getting a progosian but for
now nobody has officially claimed
responsibility for this attack okay
thank you so much
are we reporting from Moscow